jacques toubon ancien ministre de
jacques chirac il est aujourd'hui
défenseur des droits c'est à dire c'est
un homme qui supposait faciliter les
requêtes des français face à
l'administration ou face à la justice
quand quand les choses ne se passent pas
bien et lui comme il cumule sa
rémunération défenseur des droits et de
retraités de la haute fonction publique
ils touchent toujours de 30000 euros par
mois il ya des gens que ça choque mais
pas lui
je ne comprends pas que ça choque parce
que je rappelle que ce que je fais c'est
un travail à temps plein et vous venez
encore d'en faire la démonstration
depuis dix minutes c'est un travail à
temps plein pour lesquelles je suis
rémunérée conformément aux règles
d'accord alors ça c'était donc hier
matin mais tu peux vent a tourné gelée
de vin précise que hier soir sur europe
1 le même jacques toubon a dit qu'il
comprenait que c'est vrai que ça puisse
poser un problème qui est exactement ce
qu a dit chantal jouanno
oui c'est ça mais arnaud benedetti est
ce que c'est c'est la démagogie cette
espèce de chasse aux hauts dirigeants
d'administrations ont très bien payé je
sais pas si c'est de la démagogie mais
ce qui est vrai c'est que on constate
très souvent une grande sévérité de la
part de l'opinion publique et de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens vers
leurs élus et parfois aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître une moins
grande sévérité de la part de nos
concitoyens vis-à-vis de la
technostructure vais notamment vis-à-vis
de la technostructure national
d'ailleurs on a plus tendance à attaquer
la technostructure européenne que la
technostructure nationale ce qui est
assez intéressant alors que la
technostructure nationale n'est pas à
mon avis moins enclines un certain
nombre de critiques que la
technostructure la technostructure
nationale oui c'est la série aux
structures nationales mais c'est là si
vous voulez la difficulté dans cette
affaire elle est très simple on est dans
un climat où le vent de l'égalité pousse
très fort c'est ce que
les gilets jaunes réintroduisent aussi à
leur manière c'est quand même malgré
tout cette valeur qui est une valeur
forte de la culture politique française
et qui a été porté entre autres par la
révolution française qui est la valeur
de l'égalité je crois que c'est
tocqueville qui parlait de la passion
égalitaire des français et il est
évident que la sphère joignant au moment
où on a lancé le débat venait quelque
part disons polluer ce cette volonté
quand même des pouvoirs publics de
renouer un lien avec la société avec les
françaises et les français
alors est ce que c'est de la démagogie
je ne sais pas si c'est de la démagogie
mais il est naturel quand même aussi que
l'on se pose parfois la question sur la
rétribution des hauts fonctionnaires on
a expliqué avec nos impôts
c'est quand même de l'argent public donc
je trouve que ce débat est à mon avis
légitime
mais ce qui a aussi c'est qu'en france
vous avez une tradition une tradition
tradition pardon de non transparence qui
est très forte et donc je pense que
c'est ce qui pèse le plus aussi
vraisemblablement dans l'appréhension de
ce débat on n'est pas transparent alors
que les pays anglo saxons là dessus sont
assez claires et son cash et dise la
vérité sur les prix
on vous pose la question sur twitter les
dirigeants publics sont ils trop paient
et vous êtes 76% à nous répondre que oui
zarathoustra estime que ce n'est pas
tant les salaires mais plutôt les
dépenses autour de ces rémunérations qui
sont essentiels sans parler des
retraites ces gens jouent de la carte
bleue mais ce n'est pas la leur ajoute
il ou elle car je gêne york c'est un
homme ou une femme sur lefigaro.fr
pour l'instant nous dit symboliquement
on estimera toujours que les
rémunérations sont trop hautes
en pratique les salaires sont faibles
comparés au privé adrien matou votre
magazine consacré un article à ce sujet
on y apprend des choses pas triste oui
alors c'est mon confrère camarades
étienne girard qui est un peu mener une
enquête
on parlait démagogie tout à l'heure je
pense que la démagogie serait de dire
ils sont tous trop payés ça c'est faux
mais par contre il y en a certains qui
on peut penser qu'ils sont trop payés
je vous donne quelques exemples en fait
je pense que ce qui choque les gens
c'est peut-être le contraste entre
l'utilité perçue ou réelle d'un dans le
comité d'un une organisation et la
rémunération de ces mots je vous donne
juste quelques exemples tirés de
l'article de mon camarade par exemple le
médiateur national de l'énergie qui
s'appelle jean gaubert il n'exerce qu
environ trois jours par semaine ce qui
correspond aux besoins indique son
service de communication
il touche 4000 euros mensuels qui une
rémunération qui se cumulent avec sa
pension des parlementaires et avec sa
retraite classique c'est aussi ça qui
énerve les gens avec le jacques toubon
par exemple mais il ya peut-être pas que
le cumul parce que par exemple
l'observatoire des finances et de la
gestion publique locale s'est réunie une
fois en 2017
une seule réunion quatre salariés et
coûte 210 mille euros alors qu'il existe
déjà un comité des finances locales
vous retrouverez plein d'exemples dans
l'article mais voilà on peut on peut se
poser la question de ces comités qui ne
servent d'après l'aveu d'un
d'un député à leur chef en tout cas les
chefs c'est un poste que vous obtenez
parce que vous avez des relations plus
que par compétence on peut se poser la
question de ces comités qui servent à
caser souvent des copains des politiques
en place et qui ont des rémunérations
faramineuses par rapport notamment à ce
qui se fait dans la fonction publique
parce que par exemple les fonctions les
fonctionnaires leur leur salaire est
gelé depuis de nombreuses années ils
n'ont pas des gros salaires par contre
il y en a certains qui voient là qui
touche beaucoup pour peu de travail
guillaume bardin votre point de vue est
ce que la jalousie est un vilain défaut
écoutez on a évoqué quand même là des
chiffres qui sont très au delà des de la
barre des 8000 euros or on sait que une
rémunération de 8000 euros par mois
c'est 1 % des personnes en france
donc évidemment ça ça choque énormément
de personnes et on se dit que il y à un
seuil je dirais de niveau de vie qui a
été qui franchit dans ces conditions là
ce qui est je dirais important c'est
qu'il me semble que les français ne
revendique pas de l'égalitarisme ce
qu'il leur demande c'est qu'il y ait une
juste proportion entre la fonction
exercée le risque que ça représente
d'exercer cette fonction les compétences
nécessaires les comment dire le le le
les nécessités je dirais de d'avoir une
certaine indépendance et d'être à l'abri
d'une éventuelle corruption
et puis là la rémunération je crois que
ça ne choquerait personne qu'il y ait
des des commentaires des hauts
fonctionnaires ou des personnes de la
société civile qui est une autre
rémunération pour exercer la direction
par exemple d'une autorité
administrative indépendante
mais encore faut-il que ce ne soit pas
en cumul d'autres rémunérations et que
s'applique ce que l'on connaît par
exemple aux états unis le spoil system
parce que le fond du problème c'est que
ce sont ceux que les français ont le
sentiment et en particulier les gilet
jaune de voir c'est que ce sont toujours
eux que c'est toujours le même personnel
politique qui connaît un jeu de chaises
musicales
alors ils ne sont plus au ministère où
ils ne sont plus à l'assemblée
mais ils sont dans une dans une autorité
administrative indépendante et donc par
conséquent ils réussissent accumulé un
certain nombre d'activités qu'ils sont
supposés faire à 100 % pour chacune
d'entre elles
et c'est ça y est il ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas dans la réalité du
travail effectué et c'est ça qui
évidemment choquant je crois que les
français ne demandent pas de
l'égalitarisme
ils demandent une juste proportion si je
peux me permettre de large et un tout
petit élément le problème sur les
autorités administratives indépendantes
sait aussi que la rémunération n'est pas
du tout fixé c'est pas la même pour tous
par exemple la presse décrit comme
exactement à la présidente de la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés elle gère 208 salariés
chantal jouanno on gère une dizaine je
pense et elle a une rémunération qui est
vraiment inférieur très inférieure à
celle de chantal jouanno donc voilà y'a
pas de il n'ya pas d'encadrement quoi
alors on agression que c'est du copine
exactement en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que il ne fait pas bon en ce
moment à voir deux des rémunérations
trop élevé
gamin qui l'a bien compris c'est
benjamin griveaux le porte parole du
gouvernement
il parlait de sa situation mercredi soir
sur le média brut et il expliquait que
c'était pas facile tous les jours
sortez vos mouchoirs je vis pas dans un
château je suis locataire je suis pas
propriétaire à paris puisque orange
plaidoyer enfin le prix du mètre carré
être cher moi j'ai pas irriter j'ai pas
d'argent cassé donc oui suis locataire à
paris j'ai pas de voiture j'ai pas
je m'habille pas dans des costumes très
cher superbe adresse pas très loin de
10,6 bon voilà c'est comme ça et je dire
il faut aussi qu'on fasse tomber cette
espèce de mythe alors on ricane un peur
de benedetti et en même temps c'est vrai
parce que parce que le salaire d'un
ministre autour de 8000 euros je crois
c'est pas considérable par rapport à la
fréquence de la responsable ça veut pas
ça veut pas parce que griveaux
franchement je dire des interventions
deux rivaux sont en permanence à côté de
la plaque c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est à dire que oui bien sûr vous
allez certainement raison peut-être sur
le fond mais quand même le problème
c'est qu'il est un émetteur qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus audible benjamin
griveaux par toutes les zones ont par
toutes les après tout les sorties qu'il
a pu faire donc encore une fois le
discours qu'il tient et un discours qui
est totalement inaudible pour les gens
qui sont dans les carrefours qui sont
sur les ronds points
je ne crois pas que ce type de discours
réconcilie les français avec la chose
publique et avec la politique dans un
contexte qui est un contexte de grogne
et de contestation sociale extrêmement
forte
donc c'est quand même très étonnant que
l'homme qu'ils soient charge de la
parole officiel du gouvernement dont
c'est le métier
c'est à dire aussi de sentir quel est
l'état de l'opinion publique puisse
finalement envoyé des messages qui sont
des messages aussi négatif pour la
perception finalement de 2 de son
gouvernement et de l'équipe
gouvernementale
tu dis tu avais envie de défendre le
porte parole du gouvernement
pour moi il parle cash en fait c'est
aussi ça la signature du maquereau nisme
c'est vrai ce qui dit il
il a ajouté moi il a des enfants pardon
il ajoute qu'en entrant en politique
enfin on entre en politique il y a il a
fait une croix sur quatre ou cinq fois
son salaire
dans la vie civile donc comme il a un
certain âge on pensait qu'il aurait pu
faire des économies pour devenir
propriétaire nom mélanie l'algo doivent
brûler des cierges tous les jours qu'il
soit effectivement le candidat de la
république en marche aux municipales à
paris parce qu'il pour elle il est
absolument formidable
mais au delà son cas personnel moi ce
que bon je pense qu'à une passion
égalitaire
parfois une fureur égalise l'air surtout
en ce moment et au niveau individuel des
scop s'appelait la décence commune et
qui semble manquer singulièrement à
certains de ses responsables
mais il faut élargir en fait le problème
à mon avis c'est que les organismes même
qui les rétribuent enfin au nom desquels
ils seraient deux tribus et parmi les
contribuables
il faut se poser la question de leur
utilité
quelle est la crise quelle est l'utilité
d'une commission nationale du débat
public que fait-elle comme que ne
pourrait pas faire le privé par exemple
donc c'est l'ensemble du post peut-être
qu'il faudrait supprimer
il ya alors s'est passé pas cité dans
variable mais il y a
283 comité théodule a par exemple on
vient d'apprendre grâce au comité pour
l'égalité que pardon aux communes sans
pardon au commissariat à l'égalité que
l'humour est souvent vecteur de sexisme
attention attention alors je ne sais pas
combien de sont précisément rétribuer
les membres de ce haut commissariat ma
vie 283 alors je dis pas qu'il faut tous
les sucres et vient certainement du thil
mais ça mériterait d'être examinée et
d'ailleurs la cour des comptes le fait
régulièrement écrit dans le désert cour
des comptes qui elle a une compétence
d'évaluation de contrôle très
sous-employés brownie tôt nous dit
benjamin griveaux va-t-il lancer une
cagnotte
enfin interrogations du lignon il ya une
interview intéressante de jeu froid roux
de bézieux le président du medef
chez nos confères de la vie cette
semaine et lui dit que le président de
psa carlos tavares qui a un salaire
considérable de plusieurs millions
d'euros son salaire est approuvée par
les syndicats de la du groupe
parce qu'en fait il en est quasiment le
sauveur adrien matou est ce que vous
êtes sensible à ce genre d'argument
c'est à dire que si on est vraiment très
bon on peut être très très bien payés
que c'est légitime alors pas vraiment je
connais pas le salaire en question mais
alors déjà une part de variable il ya
une première différence à faire entre le
privé et public parce que quand on
travaille pour l'intérêt général on
n'est pas là pour faire du fric pour
citer un ancien président donc il me
semble que les gens attendent davantage
des dirigeants publics que leur
rémunération soit descente après il me
semble effectivement que
au delà d'un certain niveau et je pense
que les grands dirigeants du cac 40 que
dépasse allègrement on ne comprend pas
trop quelle justification morale y at-il
à toucher des salaires qui sont
faramineux surtout quand de l'autre côté
on se refuse à augmenter les salaires et
plus faible parce que cela mettrait en
péril le l'équilibré économique d'une
entreprise
je vous propose d'essayer dernier mot à
monsieur baby doc est un internaute
fidèles de l'émission qui nous dit c'est
de l'argent public pas pour l'admiration
de carlos tavares a on est revenu sur
les sur les lads miled les
administrations c'est de l'argent public
donc oui on peut être choqué ils
devraient tous afficher leurs salaires
et leurs privilèges
ou alors on reste dans le vieux monde et
nicolas joutes ce qui est choquant c'est
la charge de travail pour certains
faible par rapport à la rémunération
élevée nous passons à un autre sujet qui
n'a rien à voir même si et les sénateurs
sont pas les moins bien traitées par la
république dans sa lettre aux français
publié dimanche dernier
emmanuel macron indiquent la mention
suivante quel rôle
nos assemblées dont le sénat et le
conseil économique social et
environnemental
doivent-elles jouer pour représenter le
territoire et la société civile faut-il
les transformer et comment alors le
moins qu'on puisse dire est que c'est
une phrase qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue qui n'a pas forcément plu aux
sénateurs et en tout cas pas vraiment